research says Yemen's devastating war
has claimed 56,000 lives over the past
two years some five times higher than
previously thought
despite have being considered the
world's worst humanitarian crisis a
British charity's found that almost half
of people in the UK are unaware there's
a war there at all even though their
country is the second biggest supplier
of weapons to the country waging the
bombing campaign there Poli boy cares
more on the findings in a moment but
first here's a look at just how much of
a toll three years of war has taken on
the Yemeni people
[Music]
hi do you know what's happening in Yemen
I'm afraid I don't know what's happening
in Yemen
these are war Saudi Arabia there's some
Middle East politics I have no idea do
you know what's happening in Yemen sorry
do you know what's happening in Yemen no
it's taken the lives of thousands of
civilians and caused an unprecedented
humanitarian crisis and yet according to
a new poll almost half of the people in
the UK have no idea that there is a war
taking place in Yemen a war in which a
saudi-led coalition is conducting a
deadly campaign of airstrikes in an
attempt to drive out Houthi rebels half
the okay don't know about most things
happening internationally I can imagine
so it's terrible why do you think that
is not enough has been said about it it
depends on what the media is emphasizing
at a particular point in time which
influences public knowledge and opinion
so you think it's underreported yes the
war in Yemen isn't just another
humanitarian crisis in a far-flung part
of the world the saudi-led campaign is
being waged partly thanks to a hefty
supply of British made weapons the UK
government happens to be the second
biggest supplier of arms to the Saudi
Kingdom after the US according to the
latest figures UK military sales to
Riyadh increased by two-thirds in 2017
from the previous year the murder of
Jamal khashoggi has brought the UK's
close strategic partnership with Riyadh
into the spotlight now an increasing
number of politicians here in the UK a
call on the government to explain its
unceasing support for the saudi-led war
in Yemen perhaps if more of the public
knew about it the government would be
under more pressure to act
you